Mike Penn suddenly had a change of heart
after seeing the second Trump indictment
he says this is not something that he
can excuse this is not something that he
can ignore this is not something that he
can defend this indictment contains its
serious charges and I cannot defend what
is alleged I have to tell you the bar is
so damn low that in some way I feel like
saying good for Mike Pence he's saying
the right thing he's doing the right
thing at the same time Pence stood by
Trump for four years as Donald Trump did
bone-headed disgusting move after
bone-headed disgusting move so in a
normal country we would be saying Pence
already lost any opportunity for any
sort of Praise by virtue of what he did
while he was vice president for Trump